This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A little more than a year ago, in February of 2021, it was snowing in Austin, Texas, which is unusual. So, this is the beginning where it might be a historic winter storm here in Austin. I love this. I mean, I was psyched. It was snowing, like, really snowing in Austin. And that just, it doesn't happen much here. Moose Bouchel is a reporter at KUT,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。一年多前，也就是2021年2月，德克萨斯州奥斯汀下雪了，这很不寻常。所以，这就是一场可能成为奥斯汀历史上罕见冬季风暴的开端。我喜欢这个。我是说，我当时兴奋极了。下雪了，奥斯汀真的下雪了。这在当地并不常见。穆斯·布切尔是KUT的一名记者，
the local public radio station in Austin, Texas. So, you know, I just wanted to get out, document this storm as much as I could. But then there's this moment in the tape that I mean, it still gives me chills when I listen back to it. Big question for a lot of people right now is whether the electric grid's gonna hold up.
也就是德克萨斯州奥斯汀当地的公共广播电台。所以，你知道，我只是想出去，尽可能多地记录这场风暴。但录音里有这样一个时刻，我每次回听时依然会感到不寒而栗。现在很多人最大的疑问是电网能否撑得住。
If you remember the news from Texas, the grid did not hold up. It went down pretty much all over the state. Millions lost power for days. Some in houses not built to a stand freezing temperatures. According to at least one estimate, more than 800 people died. I am so fucking heated y'all.
如果你还记得当时德州的新闻，电网没能撑住。全州几乎都断电了。数百万人断电数日。有些人住在根本无法抵御严寒的房子里。据至少一项估计，有超过800人死亡。我真是气炸了，伙计们。
Greg Abbott, what the fuck are you gonna do about this power grid? See all these headlights, you see all these people? These are people that have had no electricity for 13 hours and they don't have anywhere else to go. Day five and nothing. Moses has been covering energy in Texas for more than a decade. He reported on the whole blackout catastrophe with his colleagues at KUT and they made a great podcast out of that reporting called The Disconnect.
格雷格·阿博特，你到底打算怎么处理这个电网问题？看到这些车灯了吗，看到这些人了吗？这些人已经13个小时没有电了，他们无处可去。第五天了，还是什么都没有。摩西报道德州能源问题已经超过十年了。他和KUT的同事们报道了整个停电灾难，并根据这些报道制作了一个很棒的播客，叫《断连》。
In today on our show, we wanted to talk with Moze about what exactly happened a year ago and how it connects to the strange history of the Texas Power Grid. So a few days after the Blackout ended, you know, we started talking about making a podcast just to explain what happened because people really didn't understand. I was hearing all these questions about the Texas power grid, how it works, and how something so catastrophic could happen in a state that is literally known for its energy industry, right? It's baked into the entire persona of the state.
在今天的节目中，我们想和摩西聊聊一年前到底发生了什么，以及它与德州电网那段奇特的历史有何关联。所以，在停电结束后几天，我们开始商量做一个播客来解释到底发生了什么，因为人们真的不明白。我听到各种关于德州电网的问题：它是如何运作的？在一个以能源工业闻名的州，怎么会发生如此灾难性的事件？这已经融入了该州的整个形象之中。
Right. I mean, I know Texas is huge when it comes to oil production, but can you give us a sense of just how big oil production is? Okay, so to give you like a sense of scale, about 15% of the entire world's oil is produced in the United States. And almost half of that is produced right here in Texas. That's a lot. Yeah, but it's not just oil. You know, a lot of people don't know this, but Texas is also the number one producer of
没错。我知道德州在石油生产方面规模巨大，但你能让我们感受一下石油产量到底有多大吗？好的，为了让你有个概念，全球约15%的石油产自美国。而其中近一半就产自德州。那确实很多。是的，但不仅仅是石油。很多人不知道，德州也是全国第一大
wind in the country. We're number one in gas, too, not to mention solar, nuclear, coal. All of that makes what I'm about to say next really surprising. The Texas energy grid for decades has operated kind of on this nice edge. I mean, in the few months after the last blackout, there were two more times Texans were warned that there might not be enough electricity to go around. Two.
风能生产地。我们的天然气产量也是第一，更不用说太阳能、核能和煤炭了。所有这些使得我接下来要说的话非常令人惊讶。几十年来，德州能源电网一直处于这种微妙的边缘。在上次停电后的几个月里，德州人又有两次被警告可能会出现电力供应不足的情况。两次。
Mm-hmm. So if you had this summin' up, why? Why is the Texas grid so fragile? Why is it on this nice edge? That's a big question. To answer it, we've really got to look back at the whole history of the grid and how Texas came to be what we call an energy island. It's the only state in the lower 48
嗯。所以如果你要总结一下，为什么？为什么德州电网如此脆弱？为什么它处于这种微妙的边缘？这是一个大问题。要回答这个问题，我们真的必须回顾电网的整个历史，以及德州是如何成为我们所说的“能源孤岛”的。它是美国本土48州中
that operates its own independent electric grid. Okay, so let's get to that history. So we're gonna start the very beginning, right? When electricity comes out. And at first it's kind of a novelty, right? But then people, you know, they start having in their houses, cities, especially they start using it to power street lights, maybe street cars. And as electricity you expand, there was kind of this like, hodgepodge mix of ways you could get it, of utilities.
唯一运营自己独立电网的州。好的，让我们进入那段历史。我们要从最开始讲起，也就是电力刚出现的时候。起初它算是一种新奇事物，但后来人们开始在家里使用，城市尤其开始用它来驱动路灯，或许还有有轨电车。随着电力扩展，当时出现了一种大杂烩式的获取方式，也就是公用事业公司。
There were some utilities that were run by cities and towns, and then there were like these independent outfits, private operators, like at the beginning, like literally a person could kind of like buy a kit, you know, you get an electric generator and you set up shop and you just start trying to compete for customers. So it's kind of like the Wild West. Yeah, it was very unregulated, but all of that starts to change as it becomes more of a necessity. Starting in 1907, states began to regulate power companies. This is Julie Cohn. She wrote a book about the history of power in the US. It's called The Great. They said, you know, this is becoming an essential service. We want to
有些公用事业由城市和城镇运营，还有一些独立的机构，私人运营商，比如刚开始时，一个人甚至可以买一套设备，弄个发电机，然后开张营业，开始争夺客户。所以这有点像狂野西部。是的，非常缺乏监管，但随着它变得越来越必要，这一切开始改变。从1907年开始，各州开始监管电力公司。这是朱莉·科恩。她写了一本关于美国电力历史的书，叫《伟大》。他们说，这正在成为一项基本服务。我们想
make sure that it's provided on a fair basis to the citizens of our state. So we will say, who can operate where and how much you can charge your customers for your electric service and you in return will promise us that you will be fair in how you provide electricity to your customers and it will be reliable. So this regulation she's talking about, it was happening in most states like the state was regulating the utilities but not in Texas. I can't say I'm surprised. Right, I mean, Texas was anti-regulation even back then. So the oversight of our power companies here
确保它能公平地提供给本州公民。所以我们会规定谁可以在哪里运营，以及你向客户收取多少电费，作为回报，你向我们承诺，你提供电力的方式将是公平的，而且是可靠的。她所说的这种监管，在大多数州都在进行，州政府在监管公用事业，但在德州不是这样。我不能说我感到惊讶。没错，我的意思是，德州即使在当时也是反监管的。所以我们这里对电力公司的监管
remained pretty light, but as the grid grew elsewhere in the country, and especially as it started crossing state lines, regulation became a bigger issue. Because then it becomes a national issue because then it becomes the purview of the federal government if it goes across the state yes it does and and it really changed in a big way when when this guy became president let me ask that's my family
一直很宽松，但随着电网在全国其他地方的发展，特别是当它开始跨越州界时，监管就成了一个更大的问题。因为一旦跨越州界，它就成了国家层面的问题，也就成了联邦政府的管辖范围，是这样吗？是的，确实如此。当这个人成为总统时，情况发生了巨大的变化。让我问一下，那是我的家人
that the only thing we have to say this guy is FDR of course. This nation is asking for action and action now. So this was the new deal era, okay? And FDR was going after monopoly power all over the place. And these big electric companies, they were among his main targets. They had become increasingly monopolistic as all these discreet local grids grew into each other and became more of these bigger kind of regional entities.
我们唯一能说的是，这个人当然是罗斯福。这个国家要求采取行动，而且是现在就行动。所以这是新政时代。罗斯福当时在到处打击垄断势力。而这些大型电力公司就是他的主要目标之一。随着所有这些分散的本地电网相互连接，并演变成更大的区域性实体，它们变得越来越具有垄断性。
And FDR wanted to check that power, especially, you know, to make sure that right pairs didn't get a raw deal. So Congress passed a law in 1935 that said, if you crossed state lines, we're going to be under the regulation of the FETs. And the key phrase there that I'm hearing you crossed state lines, what you're going to be under the regulation of the FETs. And the key phrase there that I'm hearing is cross state lines. It sounds like you can get around federal regulation if these companies didn't cross state lines. Exactly. And that is what happened in Texas.
罗斯福想要遏制这种权力，特别是为了确保用电户不会受到不公平对待。所以国会在1935年通过了一项法律，规定如果你跨越州界，就要接受联邦的监管。我听到的关键短语是“跨越州界”，如果你跨越州界，就要接受联邦的监管。我听到的关键短语是“跨越州界”。听起来如果这些公司不跨越州界，就可以绕过联邦监管。正是如此。而这正是德州发生的情况。
You know, you can imagine why it was very attractive to these Texas power companies to say, okay, forget it. We're not going to sell power to anybody in Louisiana or Oklahoma or whatever. We're just gonna form interconnected systems inside Texas and operate as we wish. I think it's interesting to note that at first,
你可以想象为什么这些德州电力公司会觉得很有吸引力，说：“好吧，算了吧。我们不会向路易斯安那州或俄克拉荷马州等地的任何人出售电力。我们只会在德州内部形成互联系统，并按我们的意愿运营。”我认为值得注意的是，起初，
Texas was not alone in this. Some other utilities stayed within state lines too. Maine had no interconnections, for example. But by the 1960s, Texas was the only state left in the contiguous United States with its own grid. And part of the reason why has to do with Texas' size? Texas, as everyone who lives in Texas knows, is a really big state. And not only are we big, but we're wide. We have two time zones. So the sun rises an hour later in West Texas than it does in East Texas.
德州在这方面并不孤单。其他一些公用事业公司也留在了州界内。例如，缅因州就没有互联。但到了20世纪60年代，德州成了美国本土48州中唯一拥有自己电网的州。部分原因与德州的大小有关。正如每个住在德州的人都知道的那样，德州是一个非常大的州。而且我们不仅大，而且宽。我们有两个时区。所以西德州的日出比东德州晚一个小时。
So Texas is like width. It means that not everybody needs energy at the same time. People in East Texas wake up, drink their coffee, turn on their air conditioning, and then gradually an hour later, people in West Texas do the same thing. That is amazing to me. That the reason why this holds together
所以德州的这种宽度意味着并非每个人都需要在同一时间用电。东德州的人醒来，喝咖啡，打开空调，然后一个小时后，西德州的人也做同样的事情。这让我感到非常神奇。这个州之所以能维持在一起，
is that just the geography of this state. So energy demand is, we've slowly across the state because it's so wide. And that means that the grid doesn't get overloaded. No one's turning on their coffee machine all at once across an entire gigantic state. Right, we can roll that power around. And there's also the weather to think about.
仅仅是因为它的地理位置。所以能源需求在全州范围内是缓慢变化的，因为它太宽了。这意味着电网不会过载。没有人会在整个巨大的州内同时打开咖啡机。没错，我们可以调度电力。而且还有天气因素需要考虑。
Electricity is needed more when there's extreme weather. But Texas is so big that there's really hardly ever a moment when there's the same weather all across the state. So that really lets you kind of move the power around where it's needed. And that's really important because having enough power to meet electric demand, that's critical. That is the name of the game.
极端天气下对电力的需求更大。但德州太大了，几乎从来没有整个州同时出现相同天气的时候。所以这确实让你能够把电力输送到需要的地方。这非常重要，因为拥有足够的电力来满足电力需求至关重要。这就是核心所在。
Otherwise, the entire system trips up and you start seeing blackouts. Maybe now we should talk about what is actually happening when a blackout happens. What is actually happening when a grid trips up and fails? Okay, so this is fun. I think the best way to explain this is to take you into a blackout. So I'm going to take a break from Texas history now, and we're gonna jump ahead in time to 1965. In 1965, the Northeast suffered one of the biggest
否则，整个系统就会跳闸，你就会开始看到停电。也许现在我们应该谈谈停电时到底发生了什么。当电网跳闸并失效时，到底发生了什么？好的，这很有趣。我认为解释这一点的最好方法是带你进入一次停电。所以现在我要暂时离开德州历史，跳到1965年。1965年，美国东北部遭遇了历史上最大的
power failures in U.S. history, and I'm gonna play you the sound from that blackout. Everyone's gone. Do the move. That doesn't sound like a blackout. That sounds like a song. So, why are you playing a song? This is everyone's gone to the moon by a guy named Jonathan King, and this was a big hit
电力故障之一，我要给你播放那次停电时的声音。大家都走了。做那个动作。那听起来不像停电。那听起来像首歌。所以，你为什么要放一首歌？这是乔纳森·金演唱的《大家都去了月球》，这是1965年的一首热门歌曲。
in 1965. So, on November 9th of that year, this song was playing on a radio station in New York City, W-A-B-C, Windows Black outhipped. And what we're listening to is the tape of that broadcast. So you can hear the music start to like wobble around a bit at the end there, sort of like, it's speed is changing. And that's because of actually what's happening on the electric grid.
所以，在那一年的11月9日，这首歌正在纽约市的WABC电台播放，窗户黑了。我们听到的是那次广播的录音。所以你可以听到音乐在最后开始有点摇晃，就像它的速度在改变。这实际上是因为电网上正在发生的事情。
And a lot of people don't know this, but the grid has a beat. It's 60 hertz or 60 cycles per second. And this is the frequency that electricity runs over transmission lines. Almost everything electrical in your house is built to run on this 60 Hertz your toaster your TV and At this radio station in New York the turn tables were synced to that frequency
很多人不知道这一点，但电网有一个节拍。它是60赫兹，也就是每秒60个周期。这是电力在输电线路上运行的频率。你家里几乎所有的电器都是为了在这个60赫兹的频率下运行，你的烤面包机、你的电视。而在纽约的这个电台，转盘是与那个频率同步的。
So when the beat starts to slow down on the grid DJ starts to notice it in the music The river and the key of our everything's right at half speed and good in me. Hey, let's do the action several minutes. God, I wish I could be that good of a DJ. That guy, he's on. Yeah, that guy is crazy. I love it.
所以当电网上的节拍开始变慢时，DJ开始在音乐中注意到它。河流和我们的一切都在半速运行，真好。嘿，让我们做那个动作。几分钟。天哪，我真希望我也能成为那么好的DJ。那家伙，他很在行。是的，那家伙太疯狂了。我喜欢。
Okay. So, so this DJ doesn't know it yet, but something has gone really, really wrong on the electric grid around Niagara Falls. And that's basically created this chain reaction that results in not enough electricity getting to New York City. So when there's less supply than there is demand that imbalance, that can fry the whole system.
好的。所以，这个DJ还不知道，但在尼亚加拉大瀑布附近的电网上发生了一些非常非常糟糕的事情。这基本上引发了一场连锁反应，导致纽约市的电力供应不足。所以当供应少于需求时，这种不平衡可能会烧毁整个系统。
And you mean physically breaking the grid here, like a physical reaction? Absolutely, like I picture sparks flying, like things literally shorting out. Right, the very equipment starts breaking down. And that's sort of damage that can take weeks or months to repair. So to stop that from happening, grid operators basically have two options. First, they can try to find more power somewhere to meet the amount of demand, or they start cutting people's power off to lower that demand.
你的意思是物理上破坏了电网，就像一种物理反应？绝对是，就像我脑海中浮现出火花四溅，东西真的短路了。没错，设备本身开始损坏。那种损坏可能需要数周或数月才能修复。所以为了阻止这种情况发生，电网运营商基本上有两个选择。首先，他们可以尝试在某处找到更多电力来满足需求，或者他们开始切断人们的电力供应以降低需求。
And that's what happened in 1965. They cut power to 30 million people. Wow. 30 million people. Did everyone just freak out when that happened? Yeah, they kind of did, actually. That blackout, it made everyone kind of take a look around and say, we can't let this happen again, okay?
这就是1965年发生的事情。他们切断了3000万人的电力供应。哇。3000万人。当这件事发生时，大家是不是都吓坏了？是的，他们确实吓坏了。那次停电让每个人都环顾四周，说：“我们不能让这种事再次发生，好吗？”
So over the next few years, electric utilities started forming something called reliability councils. And these exist basically to keep that beat that we were talking about, to keep that 60 hertz on the grid constant. So now turning back to Texas. Texas is again, by this point, the only state in the lower 48 with its own grid, so it creates its own reliability council. It's called the Electric Reliability Council of Texas,
所以在接下来的几年里，电力公司开始组建所谓的“可靠性委员会”。这些委员会的存在基本上就是为了保持我们刚才谈到的那个节拍，保持电网上60赫兹的恒定。所以现在回到德州。德州在这一点上再次成为美国本土48州中唯一拥有自己电网的州，所以它创建了自己的可靠性委员会。它被称为德州电力可靠性委员会，
but here we just call it ERCOT. And so how does ERCOT, how do they make sure that supply and demand are, you know, in balance? They do it by being the grid's traffic cop. ERCOT basically tells companies who generate power when and how much power they need to put on the grid to meet the amount of demand. Or if there's more demand than there is supply, they can also order power companies to cut
但在这里我们简称为ERCOT。那么ERCOT是如何确保供需平衡的呢？他们通过担任电网的交通警察来做到这一点。ERCOT基本上告诉发电公司他们需要在何时以及向电网输送多少电力以满足需求。或者如果需求大于供应，他们也可以命令电力公司切断
service. This is what you call a plan blackout. It's a tricky job and it became trickier later on during the oil crisis of the 1970s. Right. This is the decade when the price for oil in the U.S. skyrocket and we start seeing gas lines everywhere. Not only that, but Carter then quite literally comes out and asks people to conserve energy domestically. You know, if you're cold in your house, you know, don't
服务。这就是所谓的计划停电。这是一项棘手的工作，在1970年代的石油危机期间变得更加棘手。没错。这是美国石油价格飙升的十年，我们开始到处看到排队加油的队伍。不仅如此，卡特总统甚至直截了当地出来要求人们在国内节约能源。你知道，如果你在家里觉得冷，你知道，不要
turn up the heat, you know, just put a sweater on, put a sweater on. Many of these proposals will be unpopular. Some will cause you to put up with inconveniences and to make sacrifices. The most important thing about these proposals is that the alternative may be a national catastrophe. During this crisis, the Carter administration realized it needed to decrease the country's dependence on foreign oil. And part of how they went about incentivizing companies to produce more energy domestically was by deregulating the energy markets. Through a new top level review process, we will do a better job of reducing government regulation
调高暖气，你知道，穿件毛衣，穿件毛衣。许多这些提议将不受欢迎。有些会让你忍受不便并做出牺牲。这些提议最重要的一点是，替代方案可能是一场国家灾难。在这场危机期间，卡特政府意识到需要减少国家对外国石油的依赖。他们激励公司在国内生产更多能源的部分方式是放松对能源市场的监管。通过一个新的高层审查程序，我们将更好地减少政府监管，
that drives up costs and drives up prices. The idea was that deregulation would spur oil production in the US by encouraging investment, and at the same time they argued that it would drive down energy prices by creating competition. And so we're seeing the baby steps of the philosophy of letting the market decide at this point. Right. And deregulation really gains steam in the 80s under Reagan. So that by the 1990s, politicians were talking about deregulating the electricity market, which like we said was always kind of run by monopolies. So again, this is where Texas comes back into the picture. In the 1990s, deregulation came to Texas in a huge way.
这会推高成本和价格。其理念是，放松监管将通过鼓励投资来刺激美国的石油生产，同时他们认为，通过创造竞争，这将降低能源价格。所以我们此时看到了让市场决定的哲学雏形。没错。放松监管在80年代里根执政期间真正获得了动力。到了90年代，政客们开始谈论放松电力市场监管，就像我们说的，电力市场一直是由垄断企业经营的。所以，德州再次出现在画面中。在90年代，放松监管在德州大规模展开。
We got out of napkin and then we kind of drew out the direction we thought it ought to take if we were going to deregulate. So this is David Sibley. He was a state senator in Texas who led the efforts to deregulate back in the 90s. Sibley and a few other legislators had this unique plan for Texas and he says they drew it up on this napkin, at the back of a napkin. But basically it would let people and businesses choose where they're getting their energy from. Like they could choose their power company. So what does that mean? Like what did David Sibley think that that would look like
我们拿出一张餐巾纸，然后画出了如果我们打算放松监管，我们认为它应该采取的方向。这是大卫·西布利。他是德州的一名州参议员，在90年代领导了放松监管的努力。西布利和其他几位立法者为德州制定了这个独特的计划，他说他们是在餐巾纸背面画出来的。但基本上，它将让个人和企业选择他们从哪里获取能源。就像他们可以选择自己的电力公司一样。那么这意味着什么？大卫·西布利认为那会是什么样子
in practice? Cause I can't even imagine how you would do that. You have one wire going to your house. Like what does that mean to choose your electricity? And it's still not like this in a lot of the country. So I think it is really hard for people to wrap their heads around. But basically under this bill,
在实践中？因为我甚至无法想象你会怎么做。你家里只有一根电线。选择你的电力意味着什么？在全国很多地方仍然不是这样。所以我认为人们真的很难理解。但基本上根据这项法案，
if you're a consumer of electricity in Texas, you would get to buy your electricity the same way you buy a roll of toilet paper. You go to the store and you look for whatever brand you like, you compare prices and you pick whatever, whatever which one you want, right? This isn't the case in most of the U.S. like I said, where you still have your one utility that provides the energy to your town or your city. And I can imagine that these you know energy companies that have held these monopolies for decades at this point, they were not a fan of the David Sibley plan or you know or himself probably as a person actually. No, they were not because
如果你是德州的电力消费者，你买电的方式就像买一卷卫生纸一样。你去商店，寻找你喜欢的任何品牌，比较价格，然后选择你想要的任何一个，对吧？正如我所说，这在美国大多数地方并非如此，你仍然只有一个公用事业公司为你的城镇或城市提供能源。我可以想象，这些几十年来一直垄断能源的公司，他们并不喜欢大卫·西布利的计划，或者他本人。不，他们不喜欢，因为
you know suddenly they wouldn't be the only players in town. We had a private dinner with utility executives and told them what we were going to do. And they were very, very opposed to our bill. They didn't like it. It was very clear how much they opposed what we were doing. I mean, they were very opposed to it. I think it seemed to assume they were very opposed to it. I think it's safe to assume they were very opposed to it. I think that they didn't like to bill. So who's on the other side of this? Who is David? Who is David said we're serving in this case with this legislation? This is a fascinating coalition. Basically, you know, you had big manufacturers, factories,
你知道，突然之间他们不再是城里唯一的玩家了。我们与公用事业高管共进私人晚餐，告诉他们我们要怎么做。他们非常非常反对我们的法案。他们不喜欢它。他们反对我们所做的事情是非常明显的。我的意思是，他们非常反对。我想可以肯定地说他们非常反对。我想可以肯定地说他们非常反对。我想他们不喜欢这个法案。那么谁站在这一边的对立面？大卫·西布利在这个案例中为谁服务？这是一个迷人的联盟。基本上，你知道，你有大型制造商、工厂，
anything that consumes a ton of electricity, they'd rather be able to shop around. And because they're buying at such bulk, they can probably negotiate better prices, if the market is deregulated. Right. That makes sense. Also, you had environmentalists really on board with this in Texas. Environmentalists, yeah, they wanted to deregulate. Well, that really surprises me, so I don't normally think of environmentalists as people
任何消耗大量电力的东西，他们宁愿能够货比三家。而且因为他们是大宗购买，如果市场放松监管，他们可能能够协商出更好的价格。没错。这说得通。此外，德州的环保人士也真正加入了这个行列。环保人士，是的，他们想要放松监管。好吧，这真的让我很惊讶，因为我通常不会认为环保人士是
who would prefer deregulated markets. So what was going on there? Back in the 90s, they saw deregulation kind of as an opportunity to break things up. If you imagine that you're like an environmentalist and I don't know, Dallas, Houston, and you've been fighting some coal plant that you think has been polluting, you know, the country forever and you want to try to take it out basically. Well, here comes an economic model that might suddenly give you an ability to do that. And maybe put more renewable energy on the grid.
会偏好放松监管市场的人。那么那里发生了什么？回到90年代，他们把放松监管视为一种打破现状的机会。如果你想象你是一个环保人士，在达拉斯、休斯顿，你一直在与某个你认为污染了国家很久的煤电厂作斗争，你想尝试把它关掉。好吧，这里出现了一种经济模式，可能突然让你有能力做到这一点。也许还能在电网上投入更多的可再生能源。
And this wasn't like, they weren't far off. This actually happened. They end up writing in renewable energy goals into the bill so that when they deregulate, they start bringing in more wind power. So, Siddly's bill had the big manufacturers on board. They had environmentalists on board and was it just kind of good to go at that point? No, well, we're forgetting one other big key player in all this and it's a little company from Houston that you might have heard of before. And Ron was going around the country trying to persuade all of these legislatures and policy makers that full tilt electric competition is a wonderful thing.
而且这并不是说他们离目标很远。这确实发生了。他们最终将可再生能源目标写入了法案，这样当他们放松监管时，他们就开始引入更多的风能。所以，西布利的法案让大型制造商加入了，让环保人士加入了，那时候是不是就准备好了？不，我们忘记了所有这一切中的另一个关键参与者，它是来自休斯顿的一家小公司，你可能以前听说过。安然公司当时正在全国各地游说所有的立法者和政策制定者，说全面的电力竞争是一件美妙的事情。
And here are all the benefits that it will bring. Wow. And Ron. Yes. And Ron. Okay. This is Alice and Silverstein who worked at the Public Utility Commission of Texas in the 90s while deregulation was happening.
这就是它将带来的所有好处。哇。安然。是的。安然。好的。这是艾莉森·西尔弗斯坦，她在90年代放松监管发生时曾在德州公用事业委员会工作。
And she, like lots of folks, doesn't have a ton of great things to say about and Ron. And Ron and other traders were able to develop a number of strategies that allowed them to make a ton of money in sleazy ways. He doesn't mean to words. No, not at all. What she's talking about here is what she says, Enron's making money in sleazy ways, deregulating the energy market means that companies like N-Ron can start trading energy
而且她，像很多人一样，对安然公司没什么好话。安然和其他交易员能够制定许多策略，让他们以卑鄙的方式赚取大量金钱。他不是指言语。不，一点也不。她在这里所说的是，安然公司以卑鄙的方式赚钱，放松能源市场监管意味着像安然这样的公司可以开始交易能源，
basically kind of like a stock or a bond. So around this time, there's this famous case on the West Coast where N-Ron traders would straight up call a power plant and say, hey, can you shut down for maintenance? And the power plant is like, why? And they're like, just do it. And so what are they trying to accomplish when they do that? Basically, it's market manipulation. The more scarce something is, the more valuable becomes.
基本上就像股票或债券一样。所以大约在这个时候，西海岸发生了一个著名的案例，安然交易员会直接打电话给发电厂说：“嘿，你们能为了维护而关闭吗？”发电厂问：“为什么？”他们说：“照做就是了。”所以当他们这样做时，他们试图实现什么？基本上，这是市场操纵。某样东西越稀缺，它就越有价值。
So in this case, Enron used their influence to drive up the price of energy by making less of it available. That's a diabolical. Yeah, that is. But at this point, people weren't all that aware of all the awful things Enron was doing, right? Yeah. You're absolutely right.
所以在这个案例中，安然利用他们的影响力，通过减少能源供应来推高能源价格。那真是恶魔般的。是的，确实是。但在这一点上，人们并没有完全意识到安然所做的所有可怕的事情，对吧？是的。你说得完全正确。
And remember, Enron back then, Enron was wildly powerful. It was a corporate Titan, like Amazon or Apple. Yeah. Okay. So Enron is on board with deregulation because they think it'll open up another avenue for them to make money. Yep. And so what happens with Simply's Bill?
而且记住，当时的安然，安然是非常强大的。它是一个企业巨人，就像亚马逊或苹果一样。好的。所以安然支持放松监管，因为他们认为这会为他们开辟另一条赚钱的途径。是的。那么西布利的法案发生了什么？
Well, now it's good to go. The Bill passes and it's signing a law June 1999 and this piece of legislation, basically what it did, it was it created two key things. The first was the ability for consumers in a lot of the state to choose their own electric providers, which is what we talked about earlier. But the second thing, and this is one of the most critical parts of all this, is that this bill created what's called an energy-only market. So tell me more about that. What is an energy-only market? So Texas' energy-only market is the first and only one of its kind in the country.
好吧，现在准备好了。法案通过并于1999年6月签署成为法律，这项立法基本上做了两件关键的事情。第一是让州内许多地方的消费者能够选择自己的电力供应商，这就是我们之前谈到的。但第二件事，这是所有这一切中最关键的部分之一，是这项法案创建了所谓的“仅能源市场”。那么告诉我更多关于那个的信息。什么是仅能源市场？所以德州的仅能源市场是全国第一个也是唯一一个此类市场。
In most other parts of the country, a power plant, is kind of pay just to sit around to provide energy just in case it's needed. But in Texas, power plants are only paid for the power that they produce and sell on the market. People in favor of this system, they said it was the most efficient way to do things, but critics looked at it, and they said,
在全国其他大部分地区，发电厂会因为仅仅坐在那里以备不时之需而获得报酬。但在德州，发电厂只为他们在市场上生产和销售的电力获得报酬。支持这个系统的人说这是最有效率的做事方式，但批评者看着它，他们说，
wait a second, power plants can charge more for electricity, the less of it there is available. You know, just like we were talking about with Enron, it kind of creates this incentive for scarcity. Okay, so I'm starting to see how this all fits together. Texas operates on its own grid to avoid federal regulation, making it the only energy island in the country. It's also been deregulated to the point where there's purposely almost no excess energy on the grid, which means that when there's a huge surge in demand, like, say, I don't know, during a serious winter storm,
等一下，电力越稀缺，发电厂收取的电费就越高。你知道，就像我们刚才谈到的安然公司，它在某种程度上创造了一种对稀缺性的激励。好的，所以我开始明白这一切是如何结合在一起的了。德州在自己的电网上运行以避免联邦监管，使其成为全国唯一的能源孤岛。它也被放松监管到几乎没有电网过剩能源的地步，这意味着当需求激增时，比如，我不知道，在严重的冬季风暴期间，
a blackout isn't just likely. It's like, you know, almost a certainty. Yeah, and because it's an energy island, when the state's grid does go down, like the cavalry isn't coming, you're not going to be able to get energy from neighboring states the way that you can in the rest of the country. So this is where we found ourselves last year as this historic winter storm bears down on the state. Demand for power is expected to potentially exceed supply during parts of Monday and Tuesday.
停电不仅是可能的。这几乎是肯定的。是的，而且因为它是一个能源孤岛，当该州的电网瘫痪时，就像骑兵不会来救援一样，你无法像在全国其他地方那样从邻近州获得能源。所以这就是去年我们发现自己所处的情况，当时这场历史性的冬季风暴席卷了该州。预计周一和周二部分时间的电力需求可能会超过供应。
Help us to keep the system from being overloaded. Lord, that thermostat just a little bit. So this unprecedented storm is coming. How does the state begin to prepare? So this is where Irkott, the reliability council that we talked about earlier, comes back into the picture. You remember Irkott, it's job is to make sure that the grid doesn't break down, that we don't get to that point.
帮助我们防止系统过载。天哪，把恒温器调低一点。所以这场前所未有的风暴即将来临。该州如何开始准备？所以这就是我们之前谈到的可靠性委员会ERCOT再次出现在画面中的地方。你还记得ERCOT，它的工作是确保电网不会瘫痪，我们不会走到那一步。
And how does Irkott do that now that it's in this completely deregulated energy market in Texas? Okay, so they're still doing the traffic op thing, right? They're trying to direct enough energy onto the grid to meet demand. But like you said, now they're operating this energy-only market, which means that the incentive, basically for power generators, is to operate as close to a blackout as possible, right? You could even say that Erkott is trying to manage a grid
那么现在德州处于这个完全放松监管的能源市场中，ERCOT是如何做到这一点的呢？好的，他们仍然在做交通警察的工作，对吧？他们试图引导足够的能源进入电网以满足需求。但就像你说的，现在他们正在运营这个仅能源市场，这意味着发电机的激励基本上是尽可能接近停电状态运行，对吧？你甚至可以说ERCOT正在试图管理一个
that's kind of working directly against their interests. It's like being an air traffic controller where the planes want to fly into the ground. Oh my God. I never thought of that before, but yeah. So it's a lot of pressure to do. There's a ton of pressure, and you can hear them feeling that pressure the afternoon before the storm started. Erkott is requesting all Texans to conserve energy today, Sunday,
直接违背他们利益的电网。这就像做一个空中交通管制员，而飞机想要坠毁在地面上。天哪。我以前从未想过这一点，但确实如此。所以这压力很大。压力非常大，你可以在风暴开始前的那天下午听到他们感受到了那种压力。ERCOT请求所有德州人在今天，周日，
through Tuesday, February 16th, to the extent that they can do so safely and reliably. This is Erkott's VP of System Operations, Dan Woodfin. Here's a conference call with media basically saying, hey, people, we should stop using electricity so that maybe a blackout doesn't happen. But then the winter storm hits, and people, reasonably enough, they just can't conserve electricity. They need it to heat their homes. Yeah, exactly.
到2月16日周二期间，在安全可靠的情况下尽可能节约能源。这是ERCOT系统运营副总裁丹·伍德芬。这是与媒体的电话会议，基本上是在说：“嘿，大家，我们应该停止使用电力，这样也许就不会发生停电。”但随后冬季风暴来袭，人们理所当然地无法节约电力。他们需要它来为房屋供暖。是的，正是如此。
People are cold. I mean, during the storm, the airport in Dallas reported a 72 year low. It was negative two degrees in Dallas. Yeah. So people are under distress and they need heat in their homes. And so they cannot regulate their power the way that Urkot wants them to. But like, it seems to me that the other way to solve this is to have the power plants produce more power. Yeah, for sure. And Urkot starts trying to do that. They start,
人们很冷。我的意思是，在风暴期间，达拉斯机场报告了72年来的最低温。达拉斯的气温是零下2度。是的。所以人们处于困境中，他们需要家里的暖气。所以他们无法像ERCOT希望的那样调节电力。但对我来说，解决这个问题的另一种方法是让发电厂生产更多的电力。是的，当然。而ERCOT开始尝试这样做。他们开始，
you know, calling up power plants and saying, Hey, you know, if you can turn on now is the time to do it. But a lot of power plants just can't come back online. This is the former CEO of Irkott, Bill Magnus, talking about it back in February, 2021. One generator after another reported that they were tripped off, they were not able to operate. So for the power plants, the problem is that things just start to freeze up. They're built in Texas for warm weather,
你知道，给发电厂打电话说：“嘿，如果你们能开启，现在就是时候了。”但许多发电厂根本无法恢复在线。这是ERCOT前首席执行官比尔·马格努斯在2021年2月谈到这件事时所说的。一个接一个的发电机报告说它们跳闸了，无法运行。所以对于发电厂来说，问题在于设备开始结冰。它们在德州是为温暖天气建造的，
and they're built outside. So their equipment is not winterized and suddenly in the super cold weather, they really literally cannot produce power. Wow. So like every part of this system is failing. Right. So Irkott can't get any more power right when demand is surging. And that means one thing, they've got to start cutting power across the state. So that's what they do. And with people's power getting cut, demand does start to drop. But that doesn't work because it turns out
而且是建在室外的。所以它们的设备没有经过防寒处理，突然在超冷天气下，它们真的无法生产电力。哇。所以系统的每个部分都在失效。没错。所以当需求激增时，ERCOT无法获得更多电力。这意味着一件事，他们必须开始在全州范围内切断电力。所以他们就是这么做的。随着人们的电力被切断，需求确实开始下降。但这没用，因为事实证明
that as the demand is dropping because of these power cuts, the supply on the grid is still dropping faster than the demand. Wow. Power plants are still breaking down all over the place. And at that point, we're getting down to the frequency levels where we're in the danger zone. Remember that beat of the grid that we talked about? How the system is built to run at that 60 Hertz frequency?
随着由于这些断电导致需求下降，电网上的供应下降速度仍然比需求快。哇。发电厂到处都在损坏。在这一点上，我们正在降至危险区域的频率水平。还记得我们谈到的电网节拍吗？系统是如何在60赫兹频率下运行的？
You see, if the grid falls below 60 Hertz for too long, it causes catastrophic grid failure. That's not a plan blackout. It is a total breakdown. That would mean hospitals don't have electricity. Gas stations don't have electricity. The government itself doesn't have electricity at the offices that they're using to try to manage this type of crisis.
你看，如果电网频率长时间低于60赫兹，就会导致灾难性的电网故障。那不是计划停电。那是彻底的崩溃。这意味着医院没有电。加油站没有电。政府本身在他们试图管理这种危机的办公室里也没有电。
Wow. I mean, that's just apocalyptic. That's a Mad Max. Yeah, yeah. It's a humanitarian crisis. It's maybe like nothing that we've ever seen before in this country. So how does it end up unfolding for the people managing the grid that first night? So that first night, the frequency on the grid drops to 59.4 hertz, which is a key number because at 59.4, the clock starts. If you stay at 59.4 for nine minutes or more,
哇。我的意思是，那简直是世界末日。那是《疯狂的麦克斯》。是的，是的。这是一场人道主义危机。这可能是我们在这个国家从未见过的。那么对于第一晚管理电网的人来说，结果如何呢？所以第一晚，电网频率降至59.4赫兹，这是一个关键数字，因为在59.4时，时钟就开始倒计时了。如果你在59.4停留9分钟或更长时间，
generation units begin to trip off on their own. So the operators at Ircott literally have nine minutes to get this thing right? That's right. The way the grid is set up is that after nine minutes, power plants start disconnecting themselves across the state. Like imagine fighter pilots ejecting themselves from the plane before it crashes. That's effectively what power plants are doing, trying to save themselves from frying along with the rest of the grid.
发电机组就会开始自行跳闸。所以ERCOT的运营商实际上只有9分钟的时间来纠正这个问题？没错。电网的设置方式是，9分钟后，发电厂开始在全州范围内自行断开连接。就像想象战斗机在坠毁前弹射出飞机一样。这实际上就是发电厂正在做的事情，试图拯救自己，以免与电网的其他部分一起烧毁。
So these operators at Irkott, they have nine minutes to get things right or all those awful things we mentioned start happening. And you know what's worse for Irkott is that as time ticks off, the number continues to drop. So they basically decide that they have to throw the kitchen sink at this thing. So they order this one massive final power cut to the grid. And we're talking about millions of people who lose power
所以ERCOT的这些运营商有9分钟的时间来纠正问题，否则我们提到的所有可怕的事情就会开始发生。而且你知道对ERCOT来说更糟的是，随着时间流逝，数字还在继续下降。所以他们基本上决定必须孤注一掷。所以他们下令对电网进行最后一次大规模断电。我们谈论的是数百万失去电力的人，
because Urkats trying to save the energy system. And finally, it works. The grid begins to stabilize. There were only four minutes and 37 seconds before that nine minutes was up. The grid would have totally failed. And so this is when millions of people start waking up on Monday morning without any power. That's right, yeah, including me. Just give a sense of how icy things are now.
因为ERCOT试图拯救能源系统。最终，它奏效了。电网开始稳定下来。距离那9分钟结束只有4分37秒。电网本来会彻底崩溃。所以这就是数百万人在周一早上醒来时没有任何电力的时候。没错，是的，包括我。感受一下现在有多冷。
I want to get this cooler in I realize I have to get some big thick layer of ice off of it before I can even Wow, I tried to document as much as I could at that time. It was like nothing I'd ever lived through before and so like What are you feeling at this point? Like, it's enough of an anomaly. You don't, or you don't aware of all the things that are coming.
我想把这个冷却器拿进来，我意识到我必须在它上面弄掉一大层厚厚的冰，才能甚至哇，我当时尽可能多地记录下来。这就像我从未经历过的事情，所以就像你在这一点上感觉如何？就像，这已经足够反常了。你不知道，或者你没有意识到所有即将到来的事情。
Like, what are you feeling when you wake up and see your breath in the morning in Texas? Like a lot of people I was nervous or the weather was only getting colder. And at first, you kind of figure that power is going to come back on quickly because that's the way it's always happened before, right? These are called rolling blackouts, but they weren't rolling. See, typically, if this happens, Texans will see their lights go out for an hour or two,
当你早上醒来在德州看到自己的呼吸时，你感觉如何？像很多人一样，我很紧张，天气只会越来越冷。起初，你以为电力会很快恢复，因为以前总是这样，对吧？这些被称为滚动停电，但它们并没有滚动。你看，通常如果发生这种情况，德州人会看到他们的灯熄灭一两个小时，
and then they'll come back on, and the blackout moves to somewhere else. And the idea there's to spread the inconvenience of the power cut around. But again, on Monday, that just isn't happening. As far as the temperature in the house, it dropped down like fast. This is Carolyn Rivera. She's a retired school teacher I spoke with for our series. It was so cold in here. My bed was like a block of ice and it was like I couldn't put on enough clothes to warm myself up. We're going to keep circling back to Carolyn, who's experienced in this blackout is just
然后它们会恢复，停电会转移到其他地方。其理念是将断电的不便分散开来。但同样，在周一，这种情况并没有发生。至于房子里的温度，下降得非常快。这是卡罗琳·里维拉。她是我为我们的系列节目采访的一位退休教师。这里太冷了。我的床就像一块冰，我感觉无论穿多少衣服都无法让自己暖和起来。我们将继续回到卡罗琳身上，她在这次停电中的经历简直
awful. But I do want to take a beat here and just say how dangerous it is for people to lose electricity for extended periods of time. There are people who count on power to run medical equipment like to get dialysis, for example. And losing power means that they're unable to get these kinds of treatments. So what might just be a discomfort for some people could cost other people their lives, which makes this whole next chunk of tape, I'm going to play you,
太糟糕了。但我确实想在这里停顿一下，说一下人们长时间失去电力是多么危险。有些人依靠电力来运行医疗设备，例如进行透析。而失去电力意味着他们无法获得这些治疗。所以对于某些人来说可能只是不适的事情，可能会让其他人付出生命的代价，这使得我接下来要播放的这段录音，
kind of infuriating. As you all know, we are in an unprecedented event throughout last night and I'll date today. This is Dn Walker. She was the chair of the Public Utility Commission. The PUC oversees Irkhat and they met here to talk about the energy market. I believe that there are some current situations within the Irkott market that are causing what I'll call distortions. It may be the wrong term, but that's what I'm going to call it right now. Distortion seems to be underselling a bit. I'd say super underselling it.
简直令人愤怒。如大家所知，昨晚到今天，我们正处于一场前所未有的事件中。这是丹·沃克（Dn Walker），她是公用事业委员会（PUC）的主席。PUC负责监管德州电力可靠性委员会（ERCOT），他们在这里开会讨论能源市场。我相信ERCOT市场内存在一些导致我称之为“扭曲”的情况。这可能用词不当，但我现在就这么叫它。说“扭曲”似乎还有点轻描淡写了。我会说这是极度的轻描淡写。
You know, we've been in mode shed since about 1 o'clock this morning and that the prices weren't at the scarcity pricing. And I was somewhat surprised about that, that way to say. So explain this to me. So what is she talking about here? What Dan Walker is saying is that she surprised that the market didn't respond the way it was supposed to.
你知道，从今天凌晨1点左右我们就进入了减载模式，但价格并没有达到稀缺定价水平。对此我感到有些惊讶，该怎么说呢。那么给我解释一下。丹·沃克在这里说的是什么意思？她的意思是她很惊讶市场没有按照预期做出反应。
You see, state regulators expected that energy prices would go as high as possible. Higher prices would mean more power plants start generating more power. And so did that happen? Or were more power plants generating more power? No, because like we said, there were no more power plants left. Power plants weren't working, but that didn't stop the public utility
你看，州监管机构预计能源价格会尽可能走高。价格越高，意味着更多的发电厂开始产生更多的电力。那么这发生了吗？还是有更多的发电厂在发电？没有，因为正如我们所说，已经没有更多的发电厂了。发电厂无法运作，但这并没有阻止公用事业委员会
commission from meeting and really using the only tool they felt like they had. They stepped in and they raised the price of electricity themselves. Because that's the market mechanism that's supposed to bring more power to the grid. But really, the failure here has nothing to do with money. Like these are physical plants that are going down, so they can throw as much money as they want to, but it just doesn't matter. No, no, but we created a system where,
开会，并真正使用他们认为自己拥有的唯一工具。他们介入并自行提高了电价。因为这是旨在为电网带来更多电力的市场机制。但实际上，这里的失败与金钱无关。这些是正在停运的实体工厂，所以他们投入再多钱也无济于事。不，不，但我们创造了一个系统，
like this was the only lever they felt like they could pull to try to get things back working again. Yeah, it was just like this market orthodoxy took over and they ignored the physical reality of the grid. Exactly. And as we entered the second day and the third day of this blackout, things just got worse.
这似乎是他们唯一能用来尝试让一切恢复正常的杠杆。是的，就像这种市场正统观念占据了主导地位，而他们忽视了电网的物理现实。没错。随着我们进入这次停电的第二天和第三天，情况变得更糟了。
Electricity wasn't the only problem. Natural gas pipelines were breaking down too. And in Texas during the winter, the main source of fuel that powers the entire grid is natural gas. So not only is the power that's going out from the power plants, is there a problem there, but the fuel coming into power plants to make all that energy that's breaking down too. Exactly. And then if that wasn't bad enough, the water system starts breaking down.
电力并不是唯一的问题。天然气管道也在破裂。在德州的冬天，为整个电网供电的主要燃料来源是天然气。所以不仅是发电厂的电力输出有问题，连输送到发电厂制造能源的燃料也出现了故障。没错。如果这还不够糟糕，供水系统也开始崩溃了。
Water running into people's homes starts to freeze. People's pipes are starting to break all across the state. Things just keep compounding and compounding. Imagine being in your home without being able to even use the bathroom properly and not have enough water. That was horrifying. Carolyn's right, the whole experience was horrifying. I mean, driving around Austin during the blackout,
流入人们家中的水开始结冰。全州各地的管道开始破裂。事情不断恶化，不断叠加。想象一下，在家里连厕所都无法正常使用，也没有足够的水。那太可怕了。卡罗琳说得对，整个经历太可怕了。我的意思是，在停电期间开车在奥斯汀转悠，
I saw water shooting out of broken pipes onto the streets and freezing on the streets. I went to this one apartment complex. There was a busted, raw sewage pipe on the second floor. So this raw sewage was just spilling out everywhere, like down the stairway into the parking lot. It was really, it was wild. How did you end up ferrying
我看到水从破裂的管道中喷射到街道上，并在街上结冰。我去了其中一个公寓大楼。二楼有一根破裂的污水管。所以这些未经处理的污水到处溢出，顺着楼梯流进停车场。这真的很疯狂。你是怎么熬过
for those four or five-handed days? I mean, when did you get your power back? We were pretty lucky, you know? We lost power on our house for a few days, but at KUT, it's the station where I work. They put me and my family up at a hotel near the station because I was trying to record on all this too, right? So they put us up after the first night
那四五天的？我的意思是，你什么时候恢复供电的？我们很幸运，你知道吗？我们家停电了几天，但在我工作的KUT电台，他们把我家人安置在电台附近的一家酒店，因为我也在尝试记录这一切，对吧？所以第一晚之后他们就把我们安置好了，
we spent at home in the cold and then we got to move to a hotel. And that was on what they call a critical circuit. There's this kind of huge point of contention actually that came up in this crisis. And you'd see people post a lot of angry videos online about this too, because some parts of every community never lost power. And that all depended on what kind of a circuit they are on, where they were getting their electricity from. And so you'd see
我们在寒冷的家中度过了一晚，然后搬到了酒店。那是在所谓的“关键电路”上。实际上，这次危机中出现了一个巨大的争议点。你也会在网上看到人们发布很多关于此的愤怒视频，因为每个社区的一些部分从未停电。这完全取决于他们所在的电路类型，以及他们从哪里获得电力。所以你会看到
things like, you know, all of the businesses in like downtown Austin, a lot of the high rise office buildings and stuff, electricity stayed up and running there the whole time. And you'd see people comment about this. Also during the live streams of the public officials like Irkhat and the PUC, people would just become livid. They look at these people sitting comfortably in their well-heated office buildings, sitting there cozy, while millions of other people were just freezing you know just trying to figure out what was going to come next
比如，奥斯汀市中心的所有企业，许多高层办公楼之类的，电力一直保持运行。你也会看到人们对此发表评论。此外，在像ERCOT和PUC这样的公共官员的直播期间，人们会变得非常愤怒。他们看着这些人舒适地坐在供暖充足的办公楼里，坐在那里很惬意，而数百万其他人却在冻僵，你知道，只是试图弄清楚接下来会发生什么。
so these critical circuit areas downtown where there's fancy offices and such they've heard better than the places that are less affluent is that right that was the impression a lot of people got and i should say there's a lot of research going on uh... right now about how much grids locally in different parts of the state might really be set up like that. But the bottom line is people with less means were the ones who came out of this the worst.
所以这些市中心的“关键电路”区域，有高档办公室之类的地方，比那些不那么富裕的地方过得更好，是这样吗？这是很多人得到的印象。我应该说，目前有很多关于州内不同地区的本地电网是如何设置的研究。但底线是，经济条件较差的人是这次事件中受损最严重的。
They had less resources to get out of this whole catastrophe in tax. You would play a sump tape from Carolyn Rivera with a pipe's broke in her house. I mean, she sounded like it was extremely stressful, extremely difficult for her. How did she fare? How did she end up? So Carolyn's from a neighborhood in East Houston that's low income. It's a place that had already been really devastated by Hurricane Harvey some years earlier. People there were still recovering from that hurricane when this blackout hit.
他们没有足够的资源来摆脱这场灾难。你播放了一段卡罗琳·里维拉（Carolyn Rivera）家管道破裂的录音。我的意思是，她听起来压力极大，非常困难。她过得怎么样？她最后怎么样了？卡罗琳来自东休斯顿的一个低收入社区。这个地方几年前就已经被飓风哈维（Hurricane Harvey）摧毁了。当这次停电发生时，那里的人们仍在从那场飓风中恢复。
And you know, and so Carolyn and a lot of her neighbors, their homes are on the older side. They might lack proper insulation. And it was in homes like these where the pipes were most likely to burst. Carolyn said, she's on a fixed income, I should ask. She brings it about $1,500 a month. She said her repair is from the storm totaled more than $3,000. You just don't have that kind of money laying around to pay that type of expense for repair.
你知道，卡罗琳和她的许多邻居，他们的房子比较老旧。他们可能缺乏适当的隔热层。正是在这样的房子里，管道最容易爆裂。卡罗琳说，她是固定收入，我应该问一下。她每月大约有1500美元的收入。她说她从风暴中受损的维修费用总计超过3000美元。你根本没有那么多闲钱来支付那种维修费用。
So for a while after the storm, the state didn't allow electric companies to cut people's power. There was this moratorium on cutoffs. But by the time I talked to Carolyn a few months after the blackout, it had been lifted. So people in her situation, people in her community were facing disconnections again, but this time, not because of the blackout, but because of the bills stemming from the blackout. So, you know, she was worried she couldn't pay her bill and that risk, the risk of being disconnected was forcing her to start rationing her own electricity. Doing the day, I turned my air way up to like 83 and then when I go to bed at night, then I'll drop it down a little lower so I can rest because of the fear of getting an electric bill that I'm not able to pay.
所以风暴过后的一段时间里，州政府不允许电力公司切断人们的电力。有一个切断禁令。但当我几个月后采访卡罗琳时，禁令已经取消了。所以像她这样的人，她社区里的人再次面临断电，但这次不是因为停电，而是因为停电产生的账单。所以，你知道，她担心付不起账单，而这种被断电的风险迫使她开始限制自己的用电。白天，我把空调调到83度，晚上睡觉时，我会调低一点，这样我才能休息，因为害怕收到付不起的电费单。
And it's like in the winter, she froze and now in the summer, you know, she'd bake. And I asked her, you know, what she thought about everything, about the blackout, about the disconnections. And this is what she told me. My thoughts were this. I was disappointed and hurt, but not surprised. They have already demonstrated how they feel about poor people. You understand what I'm saying? For all the talk about markets and efficiency and profits and risk, the thing that really matters, helping the people that the system failed, that has yet to really enter the conversation here in Texas.
就像冬天她冻坏了，现在夏天她又得受热。我问她，关于这一切，关于停电，关于断电，她是怎么想的。这就是她告诉我的。我的想法是这样的。我感到失望和受伤，但不惊讶。他们已经展示了他们对穷人的看法。你明白我的意思吗？尽管谈论了所有的市场、效率、利润和风险，但真正重要的事情——帮助那些被系统抛弃的人——在德州还没有真正进入讨论范围。
They knew this area wasn't going to get any power if there was a major outage. They knew that. They knew it. They knew it. They do not care. When we come back, the blame game, and whether the Texas grid can survive another major storm. So I'm back with Moe Spussell, who reported all about last year's blackout in Texas. And you just told us the whole story,
他们知道如果发生重大停电，这个地区不会有任何电力。他们知道这一点。他们知道。他们知道。他们根本不在乎。回来后，我们将讨论“指责游戏”，以及德州电网能否在另一场大风暴中幸存。所以我又和莫·斯普塞尔（Moe Spussell）在一起了，他报道了去年德州的所有停电事件。你刚刚给我们讲了整个故事，
but I have a bunch of questions for you. And I guess the first and foremost is like, you know, how are things now? I know a few weeks back, there was another scare with the Texas grid. How are people feeling these days? I mean, people are still really freaked out, honestly. Like you mentioned, this whole past winter,
但我有一堆问题要问你。我想首要的问题是，现在情况如何？我知道几周前，德州电网又出现了一次恐慌。这些天人们感觉如何？我的意思是，老实说，人们仍然非常害怕。就像你提到的，整个过去冬天，
we've kind of fallen into this pattern where whenever a cold front comes through, it's almost like people are reliving the trauma of what happened last year. You see people going to grocery stores and really kind of clearing out the shelves sometimes, preparing for another possible blackout. There's also just not a lot of confidence, you know, that enough has been done to fix this thing. Yeah. I mean, we really didn't get into this in the main part of our story of the question of accountability.
我们陷入了一种模式，每当冷锋过境，人们几乎就像在重温去年发生的创伤。你看到人们去杂货店，有时真的把货架清空，为另一次可能的停电做准备。人们对修复这件事所做的工作也没有太大的信心。是的。我的意思是，我们在故事的主要部分并没有深入探讨问责制的问题。
Has anyone been held responsible for the grid failure? I noticed like when you were announcing different people when they were speaking, you used the word former, a lot, the former head of things. Yeah. Yeah. So like, is that part of the accountability? Yeah, up to a certain level, everybody in charge of the electric system of Texas was gone
有人为电网故障负责吗？我注意到当你介绍不同的人发言时，你用了“前任”这个词，很多“前任负责人”。是的。是的。所以，这是问责制的一部分吗？是的，在一定程度上，德州电力系统的所有负责人都在这件事发生后的几周内离职了。
within a few weeks of this happening. All the public utility commissioners and also Bill Magnus, he was the head of Erkott. I think it's safe to say that Erkott was initially sort of the focus of that anger. I totally get that people could be, or even should be mad at Erkott, but how much could they realistically do? Because like their hands were sort of tied by this system that this group of politicians created back in the 1990s.
所有的公用事业专员，还有比尔·马格努斯（Bill Magnus），他是ERCOT的负责人。我认为可以肯定地说，ERCOT最初是这种愤怒的焦点。我完全理解人们可能，甚至应该对ERCOT感到愤怒，但他们实际上能做多少呢？因为他们的手脚被这群政客在90年代创造的系统束缚住了。
Yeah, I mean, especially when it came to Erkott, like there are other people that would come forward and say like these are just kind of the technocrats, you know, these are the people that are running the machine that someone else built in fact bill magnus the the former head of her car uh... said exactly as much when when justifying
是的，我的意思是，特别是在ERCOT的问题上，还有其他人站出来说，这些人只是技术官僚，你知道，这些人是在运行别人建造的机器。事实上，比尔·马格努斯，ERCOT的前负责人，在为
their decision to cut power the first night of the blackout the fundamental decision that was made to have the outages imposed was a wise decision by the operators that we have here. If we had waited, not done outages, not reduced demand, Texas would be in an indeterminately long situation without power even more extensively than we are with these outages.
他们在停电第一晚切断电力的决定辩护时，正是这么说的：实施停电的根本决定是我们这里的运营商做出的明智决定。如果我们等待，不进行停电，不减少需求，德州将陷入无限期的停电状态，情况比我们现在这些停电还要严重得多。
So, there is the former, you know, ERCOT CEO basically saying, we did our job, you know, that the grid didn't fully melt down, so for us, like, that's a win. Yeah. Yeah. They succeeded in fulfilling their mandate. And that's basically it. Right. Yeah. And in doing that, you know, millions of people, well, you know what happened. Yeah. Yeah. So as Erkott is passing the book, um, who does it land to next? So this really was, it was like this string of finger pointing going on in Austin for months after this thing happened. So first you had the power generators, another obvious party that's responsible for this. These are the companies that own the power plants that failed to produce the electricity.
所以，那位前ERCOT首席执行官基本上是在说，我们完成了我们的工作，你知道，电网没有完全崩溃，所以对我们来说，这是一种胜利。是的。是的。他们成功完成了他们的任务。基本上就是这样。对。是的。在这样做的时候，你知道，数百万的人，嗯，你知道发生了什么。对。是的。所以当ERCOT推卸责任时，嗯，接下来轮到谁了？所以这确实是一连串的指责，在事情发生后的几个月里，奥斯汀一直在发生这种情况。首先是发电商，这是另一个显而易见的责任方。这些是拥有未能发电的发电厂的公司。
And so there's a lot of focus on them. What are you guys going to do to make sure this never happens again? But almost right out of the gate, the first thing you heard from the power plants was that it's not all our fault because we didn't have the fuel to run. Like the power generators are literally saying, and this is backed up by data,
所以人们把很多注意力集中在他们身上。你们打算做什么来确保这种情况永远不会再发生？但几乎从一开始，你从发电厂听到的第一件事就是，这不全是我们的错，因为我们没有燃料来运行。就像发电商字面上说的那样，而且这有数据支持，
is not just them saying this, the natural gas supply dropped so hard, so fast that they could not run their plants to produce electricity so they they're argument that is like we could be as ready for a storm is as ever but if we don't have fuel to run it's never going to help anything so they they point their fingers to the natural gas suppliers is or after that like does the natural gas company you know like flame somebody else. They absolutely did. I mean, the line from the natural gas industry was that their power had been cut by Erkott.
不仅仅是他们这么说，天然气供应下降得太猛、太快，以至于他们无法运行工厂来发电。所以他们的论点是，我们可能像往常一样为风暴做好了准备，但如果我们没有燃料来运行，那将无济于事。所以他们把矛头指向了天然气供应商。在那之后，天然气公司是否也指责了别人？他们绝对指责了。我的意思是，天然气行业的说法是，他们的电力被ERCOT切断了。
And so they couldn't produce natural gas to bring to the power generators because they were victims of the blackout, essentially. That was their line. Oh my God. So, I mean, was there any was their line and we're going to so it was i mean was there any truth to that that sounds horrified it's like a circular fire is got that's horrible yeah there is truth to it but it's not the whole
所以他们无法生产天然气来供应给发电商，因为他们本质上是停电的受害者。这就是他们的说法。天哪。所以，我的意思是，他们的说法有任何真实性吗？这听起来很可怕，就像一个循环的火灾，这太可怕了。是的，有真实性，但这并不是全部
story uh... the problem with that with that kind of rationalization is that a lot of the natural gas supply dropped not because of power cuts and in fact a lot of the natural gas supply in the state of Texas started dropping well before the blackouts were enacting. We saw natural gas supply get really scarce even in the lead up to this storm. So it can't all be blamed on on Irkott. I mean, and one of the aspects of accountability is like, who's going to pay for it? Because you mentioned that the Texas Public Utility Commission
故事。那种合理化的问题在于，很多天然气供应下降并不是因为断电。事实上，德州的很多天然气供应在停电实施之前就开始下降了。我们看到天然气供应甚至在风暴来临前就变得非常稀缺。所以不能全怪ERCOT。我的意思是，问责制的一个方面是，谁来买单？因为你提到德州公用事业委员会
raised the price of electricity to its maximum. That was like $9,000 per megawatt hour. And then as I understand it, the people are on the hook for that, right? Yeah, absolutely. I mean, like, there's a lot of reporting around this after the blackout. And initially what you might have heard a lot about are these like super high electric bills thousands of dollars of bills and that did affect some people in the state who had certain
将电价提高到了最高水平。那是每兆瓦时9000美元。据我所知，人们要为此买单，对吧？是的，绝对。我的意思是，停电后有很多关于此的报道。最初你可能听说了很多关于这些超高电费账单的事情，数千美元的账单，这确实影响了州内一些有特定
plans or you know electric plans but the reality is for most Texans Everyone's bill is going to be a little higher for decades to come this blackout created this kind of massive for decades to come. This blackout created this kind of massive wealth transfer, essentially, and all of this debt got transferred from power companies that had to pay these huge prices for electricity and also for natural gas. All of that debt is filtering back to the rate payer now, and it's going to be paid off in small increments
计划或电力计划的人，但现实是，对于大多数德州人来说，每个人的账单在未来几十年里都会高一点。这次停电造成了这种大规模的财富转移，本质上，所有的债务都从必须支付这些高昂电价和天然气价格的电力公司转移出去了。所有这些债务现在都过滤回了纳税人身上，并将分摊在几十年里，以小额增量支付。
month by month over decades. And we're talking, again, billions of dollars. So this is also still a very live issue. People are really pissed off about this. And they feel like they were, they were victimized by this blackout. And now they've got to put the bill and pay, pay billions to these companies that, that benefited from this energy scarcity. So like in the end, if you were to balance all the scales, you know, like, the argument for deregulation was that it was supposed to make the whole system cheaper and efficient, and that those savings would be felt by the consumer. That's what they always say.
我们再次谈论的是数十亿美元。所以这仍然是一个非常现实的问题。人们对此非常愤怒。他们觉得他们是这次停电的受害者。现在他们必须支付账单，并向那些从这种能源短缺中获利的公司支付数十亿美元。所以最后，如果你要权衡所有因素，你知道，放松管制的理由是它应该使整个系统更便宜、更高效，并且消费者会感受到这些节省。他们总是这么说。
But this doesn't sound cheaper. No, I've seen a lot of studies on this, and there are, of course, a lot of competing studies. But most of what I've seen shows that on average, your regular rate payer, your residential consumer, did not see cheaper electricity after deregulation. There are some people say that the bigger customers, the industrial customers, they got cheaper power. But your average person at home
但这听起来并不便宜。不，我看了很多关于这个的研究，当然，有很多相互竞争的研究。但我看到的大部分研究表明，平均而言，你的普通纳税人，你的住宅消费者，在放松管制后并没有看到更便宜的电力。有些人说更大的客户，工业客户，他们得到了更便宜的电力。但你在家里的普通人
didn't necessarily see better prices. And then if you add on to the fact of the billions of dollars people will now be paying off because of the blackout, well that's certainly, again, means that our system in Texas is even more expensive now than it was before the blackout. So yeah, in terms of price, it's hard to make an argument for the system
并没有看到更好的价格。再加上人们现在因为停电而要支付数十亿美元的事实，这当然再次意味着我们在德州的系统现在比停电前更昂贵。所以是的，就价格而言，很难为他们在放松管制时创造的系统辩护。
that they created when they deregulated. So beyond figuring out who to blame, have there been any reforms that have been put in place last February, so that's something like this doesn't have again. Yeah, there were. Again, lawmakers met, they passed some laws. One thing that they did was they said, power plants have to winterize.
所以除了找出该责怪谁之外，去年二月以来是否实施了任何改革，以防止类似的事情再次发生？是的，确实有。立法者再次开会，通过了一些法律。他们做的一件事是，他们说，发电厂必须进行防寒改造。
Basically, you've got to insulate yourself so you can run in the cold weather. Power plants did do that last fall before this winter. Parts of the natural gas system also are now not supposed to have their power cut if the inner blackout, which sounds like it could be helpful. But the natural gas infrastructure has not winterized. And regulators are still working on that. It's something that they hope to have done next winter. But that process has been a lot slower and a lot more controversial, honestly. The fact that the natural gas companies have not had to do that yet.
基本上，你必须做好隔热，这样你才能在寒冷的天气里运行。发电厂在去年冬天之前确实做了。天然气系统的部分现在也不应该在停电时被切断，这听起来可能很有帮助。但天然气基础设施还没有进行防寒改造。监管机构仍在研究这个问题。这是他们希望在明年冬天完成的事情。但老实说，这个过程要慢得多，也更具争议性。天然气公司还没有必须这样做的事实。
Is there any notion of just getting a real significant line out to other electrical grids in the United States, just like emergencies or something? That has been a big topic of conversation. We've heard a lot of people come out and say that not only should we do that, but that many of them argue that we can do it in Texas without even giving up our independent control of the grid, right? We wouldn't necessarily have to have tons of federal oversight. So, you know, that's a conversation that's going on, but it's not really clear whether our state leadership wants to go in that direction. I think there's
有没有考虑过向美国其他电网输送一条真正重要的线路，比如用于紧急情况之类的？这已经成为一个很大的讨论话题。我们听到很多人出来说，我们不仅应该这样做，而且他们中的许多人认为，我们可以在德州做到这一点，甚至不需要放弃我们对电网的独立控制权，对吧？我们不一定非要有大量的联邦监管。所以，你知道，这是一个正在进行的对话，但不清楚我们的州领导层是否想朝那个方向发展。我认为还有
still this idea that this was a historic freeze, right? This is something that Texas hardly ever sees happen. So, so maybe people are wondering why make an investment to fix this system that really works most of the time. I mean, I guess people can cover themselves with the idea that the system worked most of the time, but, you know, we're talking about people's electricity.
这种想法，即这是一次历史性的冰冻，对吧？这是德州几乎从未见过的事情。所以，也许人们在想，为什么要投资修复这个在大多数时候都能正常工作的系统。我的意思是，我想人们可以用这个系统在大多数时候都能工作来安慰自己，但是，你知道，我们谈论的是人们的电力。
Shouldn't that work all the time? Totally. And another problem with the idea that the system works most of the time is that these storms are happening more often because of climate change. And here I'm not just talking about cold spells, right? We have things like hurricanes. I mean, hurricane Harvey really racked Houston and a big part of the state not so long ago. We have massive droughts. You know, we get months and months at a time of triple digit heat, that also has its own effect on the grid.
难道不应该一直工作吗？完全正确。而且认为系统在大多数时候都能工作的想法的另一个问题是，由于气候变化，这些风暴发生得越来越频繁。在这里，我不仅仅是在谈论寒流，对吧？我们有飓风之类的东西。我的意思是，飓风哈维不久前确实摧毁了休斯顿和该州的大部分地区。我们有大规模的干旱。你知道，我们有连续几个月的三位数高温，这对电网也有其自身的影响。
And so it's becoming less and less possible to just say, oh, you know, this is going to happen every few decades and we don't really need to plan around it because that's just not the case anymore. Well, most, I really appreciate you sharing your story with us and telling it to our audience. And I highly recommend people go listen to the disconnect. It's fascinating to section the whole event and really worth checking out no matter where you're from. I really appreciate it, Roman.
所以，仅仅说“哦，你知道，这每几十年才会发生一次，我们真的不需要围绕它进行规划”变得越来越不可能，因为事实已经不再是这样了。好吧，莫，我非常感谢你与我们分享你的故事并告诉我们的听众。我强烈建议人们去听《断开连接》（The Disconnect）。它对整个事件的剖析非常迷人，无论你来自哪里，都非常值得一看。我真的很感激，罗曼。
Thank you so much. 99% of visible was produced this week by Moe's Boo Show, edited by Jason De Leon, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music buyer director of sound, Swan Rial. Fact checker is Graham Haysha, Delaney Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Threats the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald,
非常感谢。本周的《99%无形》（99% Invisible）由莫·斯普塞尔制作，杰森·德·莱昂编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯进行混音和技术制作，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里亚尔负责。事实核查员是格雷厄姆·海沙，德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。威胁团队包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，
Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Dawn, Sofia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Claire McInerney, Jimmy Moss, Andrew Weber, Nadia Hampton, Audrey McClendey, Matt Largy, Todd Callahan, Jake Pearlman, Stephanie Federico, and the whole team behind the disconnect at KUT and KUTX Studios in Austin. You can listen to the full series on the website KUT.org or wherever you're listening to this podcast.
薇薇安·李、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·道恩、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我，罗曼·马斯。特别感谢克莱尔·麦金纳尼、吉米·莫斯、安德鲁·韦伯、纳迪亚·汉普顿、奥黛丽·麦克伦迪、马特·拉吉、托德·卡拉汉、杰克·珀尔曼、斯蒂芬妮·费德里科，以及奥斯汀KUT和KUTX工作室《断开连接》背后的整个团队。你可以在网站KUT.org或你收听此播客的任何地方收听完整系列。
99% of visible is part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. BANG! Yes, yes, my creation, it's alive!
《99%无形》是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99%无形》的每一集往期节目。砰！是的，是的，我的创造，它活了！
Yes, my creation, it's alive! I shall call it Stitcher, Sirius XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我的创造，它活了！我要叫它Stitcher, Sirius XM。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。